has apparently left Russia after the
failure of his March for justice against
Moscow what are the implications of his
departure for the war in Ukraine
[Music]
the Wagner group has been incredibly
important for President Putin it's
delivered success in the battlefield
where the Russian army has failed to do
so classically in bakamut where
yevgenius pricklesson's Wagner group
made huge progress and eventually took
back moot after months of fighting
delivering a rare success for President
Putin
thank you
but during that time frictions between
the Wagner group and the regular Russian
army emerged it was quite clear the
Russian army was trying to starve the
mercenary group of ammunition and also
not protecting its flanks properly that
tension between yeah
group and the boss of the Army garasimov
and the defense secretary Russian
defense secretary sergai shogu
manifested itself eventually in an
effort to try to bring the Wagner group
under the direct control of the Russian
mod and a deadline was put for the 1st
of July for the the Wagner group to sign
up to the Russian mod this angered
yevgeni pragosian almost certainly led
him to March this March for justice
against Moscow
[Applause]
not necessarily trying to unseat Putin
but almost certainly trying to unseat
garasimoth and shugu now President Putin
would have watched all this from afar
and his Allegiance would either be with
pragosin or with his established
military leaders it turned out to be the
latter he went on National Television
spoke very angrily of the stab in the
back that yevgeni pragosin had delivered
to him and that seems to have marked the
end of this particular opposition
against Moscow
[Music]
in the short term it will have very
limited impact on the war in Ukraine
most of the soldiers Russian soldiers
will be pointing their rifles at the
Ukrainian enemy and will just be scared
at what's going to come next but what's
most interesting I think is President
Putin will have been rattled by what has
happened almost certainly he will his
number one priority is seizing and
holding power the most important thing
is that Putin is weakened so it's like
the spiders in a jar the one who will
get out of it will be wounded and
weakened Moscow will probably need to
withdraw some forces out of Ukraine to
bolster the defenses on his domestic
front and that will inevitably reduce
the reserves available for the Russian
forces in Ukraine the other big
important thing is that President Putin
has leaned heavily on mercenary groups
to help deliver success but of course
now they've become a threat to him so
it's almost certain that we'll see
reduced impact of mercenary groups
although to be fair as we saw in Sudan
if you try to assimilate a serving
military and a rebel group you end up
with civil war that may still erupt for
President Putin but in the near term
it'll be morale the morale of the
Russian forces will have been impacted
adversely by this they will have seen
their chaos in their headquarters the
undermining of Putin's Authority that
will not be good for their morale and
therefore by the same token Ukrainian
morale will be heightened by this but in
that in the near term we'll probably see
very limited difference on the
battlefield
[Music]
Ukraine will be focused on its
counter-offensive at the moment they're
not committing their main forces they're
probing the Russian defenses to try to
find a way through a sign of weakness
and that's when we'll see the main
forces Ukrainian forces committed to the
fight now in the near term Russian
defenses are pretty well established and
it will be quite difficult for Ukraine
to break through what we are going to
see though is almost certainly the
Russians have not got the reserve forces
that they once had and their morale will
be at a lower level as a result when
Ukraine does make a breakthrough it
could have significant consequences for
the long-term impact of the war and also
potentially any breakthrough it could
actually undermine Russian morale
completely and we could see a route but
that's all to come they've got Ukraine's
they've got to make a breakthrough first
foreign
[Music]
we can expect the war to continue
exactly as it's progressing at the
moment with the Ukraine is desperate for
a breakthrough and the Russians fighting
their defensive lines what's interesting
that's been thrown up as a result of
this is whether President Putin is
secure in the long term undoubtedly he's
been damaged in the near term but
whether he at this unseats him from
Power remains to be seen and it's very
unlikely he will fight very hard tooth
and nail to remain in power you see when
you have a one-man dictatorship uneasy
is the head that wears the crow and he
requires for his continuing power he
can't defend himself he needs to have
the Army he needs to have the
intelligence agencies some of the
oligarchs who have protected and
defended them up till now they have to
be willing to continue to do so now
these are all tough people these are all
people who are looking to their own
position and they know that Putin is no
longer a good investment and therefore
they will be already talking amongst
themselves perhaps very privately not
near any microbirms uh just you know is
this guy now a complete liability should
we perhaps go and persuade him time to
retire to his country dacha and let
somebody else take over the other
interesting aspect is uh belarus's
involvement if it's true that President
lukashenko brokered the deal that just
persuaded yeah not to march to halt his
march on Moscow and to go into Belarus
that will be a fascinating Dynamic some
Machiavellian view is that maybe
lukashenko is providing a safe haven for
pragos in so that he can mount an a
fence on Kiev at some stage in the
future to be brutally honest though if
he if Putin wanted to do that there are
much easier ways for him to move
progression into Belarus under the radar
without all the Fanfare and also without
all the damage that's been caused to
President Putin along the way from
lukashenka's perspective almost
certainly this has been a positive thing
as well he's been somewhat subjugated to
President Putin over the last few years
the this was an opportunity for him to
help President Putin in his hour of need
it also gave bragosian a way out of the
really difficult situation he had found
himself in